from stereo tips that they're always in
a hurry
yeah he paid I would go on a date with
someone for Los Angeles like we're not
I've had I would not have very high
expectations
in New York it's dark it's very
fast-paced rat race the dragon the worst
thing about working at no laces a lot
more chiller in New York this is a
little bit more I patient high-strung la
seems to be pretty pretentious very
relaxed and a little superficial I mean
there's no Sun and like people don't
work out as much so people kind of like
let themselves go in the winter they got
a lot of trash on the street just kind
of seems like people would be in worse
moods or stuff it's like a city building
cause so you don't have a cod and
worst thing we're working in New York
City being in New York City New York is
so much more expensive to be honest I
Love New York gladly Callie is he a my
speed actually with the vision
California LA a couple of a couple two
years ago and I just fell back in love
with just the California scene you know
to be honest that's that's pretty much
in my five year please
yeah
I like New York